last week I told you about the
multi-billion dollar arms deal that the
Trump administration signed with Saudi
Arabia of course Saudi Arabia one of the
biggest sources of terrorism around the
world over the last who knows how many
years a totally oppressive and violent
regime and yet still we continue to do
big arms deals with Saudi Arabia so
Trump gets back from his trip in Saudi
Arabia a press conference is arranged to
talk about the trip an acting assistant
secretary for Near East affairs Stuart
Jones was tasked with answering
questions from journalists about the
trip the last question was asked by Dave
Clark Dave Clark is a reporter with the
Agence france-presse he created one of
the most Awkward cringe-worthy moments
of press conferences under the trump
administration and that says a lot
because there have been no shortage of
those I mean Sean Spicer his press
secretary officer after all
let me first read to you the question
that was asked by Dave Clark and I hope
you're prepared for this because this is
going to get really bad so the question
from Dave Clark was quote while you were
over there the secretary criticized the
conduct of the Iranian elections and
Iran's record on democracy he did so
standing next to Saudi officials how do
you characterize Saudi Arabia's
commitment to democracy and does the
administration believe that democracy is
a buffer or barrier against extremism
brilliant question right how can you
criticize Iran's democratic process
while you're standing next to and Trump
dancing with people from Saudi Arabia
diplomats from Saudi Arabia doesn't
really make sense
this froze Stewart Jones for nearly 20
seconds it's gonna feel like five
minutes because it's so cringe-worthy
it's only twenty seconds and then he
gives just an insane non answer did this
is one I mean this was like a robot
malfunction it reminds me of when Marco
Rubio repeated the same thing four times
during one of those Republican primary
debates it seemed like Stewart Jones
malfunctioned here take a look and
listen at this the secretary criticized
the conduct of the Iranian elections and
Iran's record and democracy did so
standing next to Saudi officials
howdy characterize Saudi Arabia's
commitment to democracy and does the
administration believe that democracy is
a buffer or barrier or against extremism
go on I think what we say is that at
this meeting we were able to make
significant progress with Saudi and GCC
partners in both making a strong
statement against extremism and also and
also putting putting in place certain
measures through this GCC mechanism
where we can combat extremism clearly
one source of extremism one sword one
terrorism threat is coming from Iran and
that's coming from a part of the Iranian
apparatus that is not at all responsive
to its electorate yeah get him out of
the room so that was it that was the end
of the press conference I almost feel
sort of bad for him because he's being
asked to defend the indefensible it's
not Stewart Jones's fault that we have
this indefensible depraved friendship
and alliance with Saudi Arabia this has
been indefensible by the u.s. for
decades right this friendship with the
Saudi government and immoral friendship
a depraved friendship Saudi Arabia is a
hereditary Sunni monarchy and the global
source of radical Islamic terrorism and
yet it is an ally of the United States
Iran is a you know I we can't call it a
Democratic Republic because because it's
not but it's it's ostensibly semi
democratic which just held at least what
we could consider elections where there
was a reform candidate that that was
seeking greater ties with the west and
cleaned the clock of the conservative
hardliner but that is an enemy of the
United States I'm not saying that Iran
shouldn't be an enemy of the United
States what I'm saying is the double
standard and the hypocrisy with regard
to the Saudi Arabian relationship is
utterly indefensible the question is
actually
unanswerable in a way that makes sense
to humans with brains capable of logic
and clearly Stewart Jones wasn't able to
get around that maybe we should be
commending Jones for even being able to
put together that not answer but just a
total implosion and again these
questions are not answerable because the
policy does not make sense and that
became completely evident when Stewart
Jones froze for twenty seconds before
being able to muster irrational
haphazard talking points I almost feel
bad for the guy but not really today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS